we're gonna have a good time to the sky
we got a spark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
long time
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm ready to roll
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is finally [ __ ] Friday we got to
get down on Friday I'm getting down at
the Turning Stone Casino tonight get
down with your favorite comedian and a
couple stones it's like what more do you
need yeah just don't tell me with them
exactly
happy Friday we hope everyone is
enjoying the deliciousness that is
Friday yeah it's a great Friday here in
New York we really we worked really hard
for it before we get into any of our
usual nonsense
I have a very exciting update for
everyone regarding merch because the
toastie Lite sweatshirt was just a crowd
favorite jacket it took the fashion
industry by station the fashion industry
by storm Anna Wintour shaking we ordered
so many and they sold out within minutes
and we felt really badly that not
everyone could get one so we came up
with a solution and as of right now live
on the site you can pre-order a toasty
sweatshirt any size you want as many as
you want
pre-order them they will ship by January
6 so they will not come in time for
Christmas but you will have them for the
winter you will have them forever so if
you were dying for a toasty like
sweatshirt they are now available for
pre-order at shop morning toast comm
shop morning toast comm so make sure to
get one if you are dying for one because
we just want everyone who wanted one to
be able to have one because they're so
freaking cute it's my favorite favorite
holiday sweater and winter sweater and
it would just be such a shame if you
know the people who wanted them couldn't
wear them I agree well are starting to
get their merch and it's so cute the
content is so premium the mugs the
onesies the sweatpants like I'm just
living if you didn't you don't take a
picture of it and you don't slap check
you a flow on it like you're not really
a toaster yeah there are these like tag
that's just so that we can enjoy with
you I got the new iPhone I don't have to
say one of the most annoying things
about like starting new is all the
presets that I had to unload it I had a
minute stands I had like all three packs
of yours I had some random ones I bought
on Etsy like really [ __ ] in a way
look I'm gonna need to devote a full
hour to get them all redownload it yeah
you will but it's it's worth it it's oh
my god it's totally worth a I'm gonna
log into Lightroom and we'll see it I'll
be there yeah but I logged in with my
Facebook and now my facebook is logged
in it's just like a whole mess Rama
can do much drama and success it's so
uninteresting - the average podcast
listener I can't even go into the
details understood well I am getting a
new phone soon very exciting for me and
I hope that when I login they'll be
there but I could also use with juice
with some rearranging of my presets yeah
I'm like which order of I that I use
most so I wouldn't mind if they all know
me there um I just wanted to tell you I
had such a you know a night in New York
last night like I was being Carrie
Bradshaw driving around town with my
kitten heels complaining about how I
have no my name when I don't have a job
you know like that's okay about job and
I went to no but mine I was packed by
the way if you're looking for like a
finance meathead you've got to go to
Nobu on a week and I Nobu 57 over
downtown t7 all the the corporate men
they work in Midtown and they all flock
to Nobu 57 I just can't believe that you
would go back there after the crime that
was committed yes your husband Ben saw a
pube and it was unfortunate but you know
what look we live in New York it wasn't
a cockroach I just can't explain how
it's not a big deal I just want to
explain why it's so much more of a big
deal than what you've just described it
as because for those of you who don't
know what happened was then went to Nobu
he ordered he did his keto was a he
filmed yellowtail sashimi he filmed
everything he was eating you know filmed
it posted it ate it and after he ate it
people were pointing out that in the
video there was a hair and he consumed
the hair but did he die no and I'm sorry
there are so few of the system
restaurants in New York that are
actually delicious and a hot spot are
fleeting and I'm just not about to pick
up and leave because somebody you know
shave their pubes on Ben's yellowtail
sashimi yeah and you know what happened
to that not you right no I haven't been
attacked yet and my meal yesterday was
so [ __ ] delicious so good it's such a
good restaurant I'm sorry I just I won't
let it be ruined its first of all not
only is it always popping like you can't
even get a reservation so annoying but
like makes you want to go even more
always celebs literally who did I see
last night more and Michael's having
dinner with Seth Meyers Seth Meyers is
like escorted the restaurant I mean
literally sprinted to his table like I
never sent anyone jog in the restaurant
before it was like so nervous and that's
the only reason I'm it was like I think
he was doing in it in an effort to just
like be like no blood to be like to be
an indirect Ito Loki but literally he
drew so much [ __ ] I shook the whole
restaurant Oh sitting on the second
floor
literally he's chicken and I was like
who's running I was like ah with Seth
Meyers like way to be incognito bro
totally totally but it's just
like such a fabulous night I'm so happy
for you and then me I went to dinner
with my friend Abe who is like the only
person who sings more than me he's like
so annoying with the singing and like I
get why you people think it's annoying
when I sing because like I hang out like
a prude work things I'm like oh it's
annoying but so obviously we went to
karaoke when we were like industry where
for literally we had to go five blocks
we were in they were for 45 minutes like
we I was making him listen to Taylor
Swift and we finally get to the karaoke
place and like I didn't think a karaoke
night on a Thursday would be pop in oh
my god she's like 45 minute wait for a
room and I was like whatever so just
like ruin the night we ended on a sour
note you know like yeah all this work to
get to karaoke and we couldn't even
carry okay
I'm so sorry very sad very sad well I'm
still a fabulous night in New York I'm
glad you had a fun night speaking of
sushi you wanna hear crazy story Wow
okay what a transition because I ordered
sushi the other night and it my post
meat was just like sitting there for so
long not mob a restaurant no like in on
intro in Murray Hill just like sitting
not moving you're real know and I texted
him and I was like is everything okay
like you haven't moved for a while it
was like 30 minutes and finally I got a
response and he's like sorry my bike got
a flat tire
I'm walking like ah what do you do do
you call triple-a when you're like it's
a flat now you're on your own
that's why having a bike in New York is
seriously out of it it's is a war out
there you ever see how people chain up
their bikes to buy like two bus stops
it's tough because people you could
chain it up someone will steal your
wheel it's like a thing in New York that
I've ever seen just random bikes
yes I saw one yesterday I saw half a
bike no wheels I was like is this
Chernobyl why are there just like random
bicycles left around so now because like
there was a bandit running around town
stealing people's wheels now if you're
really paranoid about your bike you can
lock it up to a pole and you take your
wheels off and take them with you so no
one can steal them so if you ever see a
bike with no wheels the owner might have
taken the wheels himself so no one would
steal them that's crazy that's probably
what I saw that is a level of petty
crime happening in New York right now
it's lawlessness things DeBlasio it is
lawlessness in here in New York people
can't even leave their bikes on the
street for a minute without getting
their wheel stuff and no idea that this
is what's happening it is any justice
for the bikers it is a deep and vicious
crime so upsetting
so it's
very upsetting um I can't believe it I
can't believe this is happening ever see
someone likes stealing wheels
you should I be reprimanded of course of
course I would you know how about you
know me I'd come out guns blazing
terrible in the sense of the little man
of course terrible terrible stuff well
we have a great show for you today we
actually have like a wide range of
stories slow news day
no well I guess quick news a no a slow
news day is like when we're talking
about like what a celebrity ate at a
restaurant well we never do or like who
unfollowed who or Mary Webster's word of
the day that's a big a story that is a
big story that is in the words of Harry
Styles a sign of the times it is a son a
slow news day is a comment on somebody's
Instagram like some you know is so
commented this totally but that's not
what we have we just have a wide range
of stories and you will see why okay I
just didn't know if you were promising
that being like hey we have shitty
stories today usually I'll say it's just
these are the new news that you maybe
need to know not really because like if
you want to hang out with us you can
stay and listen to them you should wanna
hang out with us for a couple cool girls
and night booms for dinner I also have
some buddies news stories and I'm really
focusing on his news because something
crazy happened yes Jackie the craziest
thing ever happened in the entire world
the craziest thing that happened on
Instagram and crazy things happened on
Instagram all the time but for some
reason I feel as though this is the
craziest right and I know that there are
toasters in high places who work on
brand social teams and are really always
like Red Bull every now and then will
comment on our Instagram on the morning
shows because I know that if the girl
who runs the incident was a toaster and
she's just like doing her part right and
but Red Bull is on brand to be
commenting on our Instagram totally we
love Red Bull we would love to drink red
Bull sponsor you know sitting here
drinking Red Bull every morning if
that's what Red Bull well like Jeffrey
star only if that's what Jeffrey only if
that's what Red Bull won like Jeffery
storm Brandi Redmond in Thailand
totally brand new red nose she was like
she wasn't vodka Red Bull he was like
yeah she's like yeah it's so exciting so
exciting um but even more exciting was
the fact that the verified Harvard
Business School Instagram account with
400,000 followers commented on her
Instagram like what in for some biz news
some
yeah what if you recognize us know that
you're using a toastie reference
feel like there they are business so but
okay and then they've really got me
because you know they have that that
business program where it's not like
real Harvard Business School it's like a
six-week thing where and they have a
master class they had a lot of
influencers do it and I don't know if it
was like a paid partnership I know
Caroline Wozniacki did it and she was
like always posting about it I'm Mariana
Hewitt did it and actually um I was just
gonna have his home in oh yeah well I
don't know he might have done like a
real Harvard Business will program they
have like this expedited thing for like
people who are like excelling already
I'm actually was jamming with Mariana he
went like asking how it was she said she
loved it and I think maybe like it
realize that you DM with Mariana Hewitt
that's so exciting for you yeah
so I I think maybe they want us to come
that's what this is all about if that's
what this is about I would love to be
there and let me know my dad's are
packed what do I pack look it's podcast
only for six weeks a hundred percent I
could totally be a Cambridge Justine a
hundred percent what like it's hard yeah
be there no we'll have to drive up in a
pink convertible I think and I would
love that more than anything without
isn't truck behind us Harvard Business
will like let us know what you need from
us checking will drive up in a pink
convertible with our with our moving
truck behind us and then we'll open the
door and you feel a little bit of water
these chairs come out yeah we're so down
Harvard like whatever you need we're
flexible we're available
also if you run a brand like on social
media and you want to comment on the
toast like please do yeah it really it's
such a thrill it brightens my day and it
also makes me worried about how many
other interesting comments like that I
might have missed along the way no I
think like God has a way of making you
see things that you that you need to see
God like and Mark Zuckerberg but the way
Instagram works like if something is
pertinent like usually it ends up coming
across your desk yes but I don't know
what the Harvard Business School mom was
like really buried in there I guess I
would never have seen it if you didn't
tell me I was just really curious about
what people were saying about like
something specific about us I suppose
was it I was on our show photo from
yesterday was I was looking - thank God
I didn't want the Dean of Admissions
like to think I was ugly right they
would never get it never OMA strips to
the cake oh my god I have got my special
events calendar like well organized he's
really doing actually like I do need to
get my social events calendar organized
um but not before I deliver what I've
gotta deliver it is time for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's time
and I don't want to you know step on
your toes or you know I know you've
things to do today I don't want to you
know get in the way of that but I have
something to say I always make time for
you my voice needs to be heard and I
feel like if it's not heard I would be
so upset like I would be remiss I would
be devastated maybe I would definitely
be heartbroken for sure if I didn't let
everyone know that today's episode is
brought to you by society6 looking for
thoughtful unique gift this holiday
season then you need to check out
society6 it is an online marketplace
home to hundreds of thousands of
creatives around the globe artists can
sign up to sell their original artwork
on dozens of product types it's the
perfect place to find unique gifts while
supporting a global creative community
they have a community of over 350,000
independent artists from around the
world you can find anything from wall
art to furniture to home decor and
lifestyle accessories no matter who
you're shopping for you're sure to find
a perfectly unique gift for everyone on
your list
we actually just placed a very big order
from society6 because they have many
throw pillows blanketing in toast DJ
horse yeah they really do Natalie it's
like very toasty very clean very pastel
I have a nice to see my at home the best
part of shopping from society6 is that
every purchase pays an artist so they
empower creativity across the world by
allowing artists to keep doing what they
love the how Taylor Swift of them there
are literally millions of designs to
choose from you're sure to find
something that you love they have a huge
array of products from wall art to throw
pillows to yoga mats to phone cases to
wrapping paper it's the go-to place to
shop for creative gifts for everyday
life it's custom-made for you so you
choose what you love society6 makes it
to order and ships it directly to you
it's nice to know that your gift was
designed by an independent artist and
not just grabbed from a shelf and
warehouse but it was actually crafted by
an actual person so if you want to give
a thoughtful and unique gift this
holiday season with society6 you can get
30% off and free shipping when you use
our code toast at s6 Co slash toast
again that's letter S as in Sam six dot
Co slash toast and use the promo code
toast s6 Co slash toast promo code toast
society six design your everyday with
art you love sign on design amazing ok
first story a little like fair before we
get into the heavier stuff here's
Brosnan is joining Camilla Kibeho in an
upcoming rendition of Cinderella Pierce
Brosnan James Bond yes I get him in
Pierce
organ confused oh and I get Pierce
Morgan and mr. Darcy confused you'll
never know that guy's name we talk about
the show on the time Henry something
he's from what a girl wants
oh yeah he's from the mother actually
Joey he's run my favorite [ __ ]
superhero Elmo's fine with me
Oh keys man Kingsman his name is Hades
Henry and when a girl one yeah but it's
not Henry that's why you're gonna meet
these Colin third birth not to be
confused with Colin Farrell no I don't
know if it's confers it's Colin Farrell
that just gave me I think it's Colin
Todd you're confusing me I never like
what's confused about it okay first Eve
I he can get it yeah well so can pierce
brosnan shout out mrs. Doubtfire well
look at this picture of Colin Firth hot
he still looks like that Pierce Brosnan
will play the King opposite Camilla
Kibeho in writer-director Kay cannons
new talent wait I'm sorry L appreciate
Brosnan is not James Bond Pierce James
we who's James Bond Daniel Craig right
right right but I think Pierce Broughton
used to be yes okay yes yes okay and
mrs. Doubtfire I'm just feeling like a
like lovely boyfriend that like had two
children course it was a run by flushing
it was it was truly was and he got the
Mercedes symbol stolen off his car which
by the way I was walking in the shooting
I saw a Mercedes with the thing off and
I was like mrs. F I was very cool
the sequel any as we reported a while
ago that Camilla kebaya will be playing
Cinderella in an upcoming like reboot
live-action version which is very
excited directing Mike a cannon of pitch
perfect fame and now we are hearing that
Pierce Brosnan is a part of it also
Billy Porter
idina menzel and Nicolas goal in C are
also confirmed to star in the film which
was released in theaters next February
but like who plays who who was Pierce
Brosnan he's the king
so his son's dad okay yeah um I believe
idea Menzel would probably pay fairy
godmother for evil stepmother
I didn't evil stepmother I think Billy
Porter would be fairy godmother oh right
I like that I'm sure writing I'm sure it
says somewhere yeah but like it's just
like some made-for-tv [ __ ] or it's a
real cinematic experience it's a real
cinematic experience this is a top-tier
caste but didn't they just reduce
Cinderella with daddy 2015 with little
girl who should have been famous but
never really became a star yeah justice
for her because she's from originally
she's from Mamma Mia after that yeah but
what what catapulted her to fame that
she was able to be in Cinderella I don't
know she was always a name of Thrones no
she was also in the movie yesterday met
you know I hate it I know but did you
actually see it yes unfortunately also
Richard Madden was in the old Cinderella
which is like sad for that version that
they're making it again six years later
um well I can't believe that's six years
between the two but I guess it's for
some reason it just didn't land whenever
some TV I always recordings I'm like I
really want to see the full version I
never watch it I don't know why I never
saw it I just wasn't inspired with the
casting choice um but speaking of
Cinderella last night I watched I take
on the classic tale in the new a
Cinderella story with Gregg Sulkin
and warmer on him Oh is there another
one yes so they need a Cinderella story
with Hilary Duff and then they started
making all these same versions out but
another Cinderella story was Selena
Gomez friend and Jennifer I'm blanking
on people's names today who plays
Stifler's mom yeah yeah yeah oh no she's
in a regular Cinderella story yes then
Selena Gomez was in one Lucy Hale was in
one and uh maybe there was one more
they're all great and now we have a new
one with Laura Morana I'm Gregg Sulkin
and it's on Netflix and it must be
successful if they keep coming out with
different franchises even though Hilary
Duff is always though J a cute premise
and I really enjoyed the movie like
where we stand Gregg Sulkin here at this
show I just wanted to support him but he
did such a great job and I even like
Laura Marano and I would recommend if
you like like a cheesy holiday flick go
for it
I don't like live for Laura Marano like
in any way that you know I thought that
movie that she did on Netflix with no
centennial was like horrifying and I
think that her character in Austin &
Ally was like so rude to everyone so I
don't like live breathe and die for her
but like maybe I'll watch it just
because we do like we said support Gregg
Sulkin ya know and I think it might make
you like her more because I went into it
definitely biased against Laura Marano
just
I know that you don't like her oh yeah
you did it for me mom but by the end I
was like she she was great they were all
right and it was a cute really cute take
classic take modern take on a classic
tale but you know what it's like when it
comes to movies you and I are just so
different yeah so maybe I actually
wouldn't like it I'm not saying that you
should watch it oh you should watch it I
got it okay so not me but you yes got it
okay exactly my hallmark is you know
we're at Miss Teen Miss I can't dumb
[ __ ] movies that's my crew I just
rather watched friends for the
thousandth time exactly oh my god I was
being so I was being the person at the
restaurant last night who you wanted to
murder do you know any mean so because
it was so packed we were sitting at the
bar for like thirty minutes before our
table was actually ready and I obviously
everybody had like two margaritas and I
was like laughing sorry because I
haven't seen my friend Aben so long and
you know when I laughed I like throw my
head back I was like not a bunching
people I was just like I was being so
loud and annoying like everyone wanted
to help me thank God the woman that I
like kept knocking into and like she
want to kill me I finally turned around
and she was like I'm gonna love your
Instagram I was like I'm gonna I think
you please don't tell everyone I'm so
annoying then we got upstairs and I'm
with my friend Abe who loves friends
more than me like way more than me so he
started playing heads up the friends
edition like we were just being stoned
we were bringing the people in the
restaurant like who needed to be
escorted out you know yeah but still had
a great time I'm happy for you know that
I am okay this next stories for you
because Harvey Weinstein has been
spotted without his walker
it's the I was like why is this story
for me Harvey Weinstein is the only
using one for sympathy
oh man who wrote this article a genius
page sake has the exclusive because he
was spotted in Bedford New York at a
target without his Walker that is so
funny I told you I was on to something
on this man Brandon Lee comes out with a
walker with yellow tennis balls on it
and it's just confusing yeah it's
confusing and I was thinking maybe I'll
give him the benefit of the doubt you
know there's a lot of steps to take in
at the courthouse but you know what else
has live steps to take in target so if
you need a walker at the courthouse you
need a walker act especially one in the
suburbs like maybe it was a super target
even like a percent the the mileage that
you accrue in a target is that of a
marathon right so he's totally totally
faking it one of those motorized chairs
right which by the way I you know thank
God don't need any help walking I still
take a motorized chair
at Target I feel like if I'm not if I'm
taking them and Harvey's not something
here is weird and I knew it I knew I
felt something weird about that Walker
yesterday and I'm so glad I brought it
up because now we know for sure
[ __ ] [ __ ] him he's totally playing on
our emotions so [ __ ] up I mean I don't
think that he's gonna garner any
sympathy no um and this is just
hilarious but you know it's like
sometimes if you're committed of a crime
or you're in prison and you're you're
super old or like you're diagnosed with
cancer they do like let you go there is
something like a like Bill Cosby's blind
right or like in Shawshank Redemption
that old man did they let him out
because he was old or because I don't
remember remember and who ends up kill
himself that I think is the saddest part
of the movie when he gets out of jail
but he like misses the camaraderie so he
just kills me oh my god cuz he hates his
life of bagging groceries and living in
like a halfway house oh my god that
movie is [ __ ] depressing it's like
what I'm sad you like I've only seen it
once start to finish and that wasn't
enough for me like I don't know what
what to be sadder about like he shovel
he first of all he was innocent the
whole time he shovels his way to freedom
through [ __ ] or the old cute man who has
to kill himself because he hates life
outside of prison yeah like such a
[ __ ] terrible movie why are the most
pathetically acclaimed movies like in
the most deprived in Chima why can't a
comedy be like the best movie ever well
that's where they're headed now like
crazy rotations this variety ever it's
just like what a [ __ ] terrible day
but a good movie terrible but good you
know a good but like terrible okay um
next story FCC Reddy's plan to make
reaching a suicide hotline faster and
easier so the FCC is expected to advance
the proposal on Thursday to let
Americans reach a nationwide suicide
prevention hotline by dialing 988 so
it's like dialing I'm online Oh
automatically connects you to a suicide
hotline like in an emergency situation
the move comes amid widespread concern
about the country's rising suicide rate
I think this is such a great idea
michio I never thought of like I guess
9/11 is like so accessible because it's
three numbers and they thought of like
how there should be more yeah like a lot
of suicide hotlines you know they have
like one eight hundred seven digits
exactly and this will make it easier for
everyone to know and
just be like second nature for Pete
that's genius yeah it's like you have to
be careful because you can come up with
too many three digits because I'm people
will get confused but there should
definitely be more than one and again
this is a worthy cause I took a great
spot so I hope it goes through what it
has in order to become a three-digit
number you have to like the sto yeah
yeah it would be like a government thing
oh so it's never gonna happen the
government it's useless I don't know
it's happening on Thursday maybe if
there was a maybe maybe if there was a
bill that they wanted to make a three
digit number to stop selling tool pods
it would happen that's apparently the
only bill that can get passed right
exactly so that's like took it took gay
marriage like what like a hundred years
to give us Jul pods in a week totally
the FCC will have to vote again to
finalize the proceeding once it's done
collecting comments the agency projects
an 18-month timeline for implementing
the plan after that vote oh my god that
is such a long time like I said never
gonna happen
but Jill pods mysteriously got banned in
what a day ya know it was like you have
two weeks till I have all the jewel pots
in the city Oh think it was two weeks I
was so nuts like then I bought up all
the Jill pots in city I actually had a
whole stash of mango pods that I just
recently threw out because I am fully
Joel free you could have sold them from
like I know but I'm not gonna contribute
to the black market and you know
euthanization of our lungs yeah so I got
rid of them I do a few - no I'm kidding
I really threw them white like 100 I did
it one actually this morning you know
what's so crazy I don't think I realized
how much of a problem I had because I've
been like spring cleaning so I cleaned
out on my makeup all my drawers and all
this like little area in my apartment
where I just like throw [ __ ] and I must
have accrued like ten chargers and like
five jewel sticks and like 30 pots like
I and I was literally like a hoarder
like holding on to them like I had to
throw them away but I don't even think I
realize how much of a problem I had
because I think I like I had one jewel
no I had like 13 yeah well I'm glad I'm
glad you kicked the habit
me too I feel really good about it like
I don't really feel like it's been
difficult like I feel like I'm so
genuinely over the jewel yeah it made me
every now and then when I'm having a
drink like last night I was like damn oh
my I had my jewel but like not enough to
go run and get one which I pack in the
day I'm gonna get it left the meal and
went to a bodega and bought one on you
percent so it's like it's more I don't
even know if it's like the nicotine it's
now it's like a an emotional thing like
I am so over the jewel like the way I
felt when I woke up after like literally
being the jewel so hard 3 days in
Morocco like I will never want to feel
that way again and I'm genuinely over it
so that's what it was it wasn't the
government that convinced you to sound
totally was not it was Morocco like I
cuz you know in Morocco everyone like
they'd smoke hookah like it's everyone
smokes inside it's very like a smoke
friendly and we were like drinking
partying every day every night that I
was like I need my jewel and I went
through three pods in three days which
is [ __ ] disgusting and I woke up on
Monday I woke up on Monday ready to go
home and I literally left my jewel on my
nightstand and I never looked back
I felt so disgusting and I'm like so
disappointed in like the damage I must
have done to myself in like I jeweled I
drooled from I started drooling in my
mom or it may Coachella no but like
drooling I used to just jewel like when
I was out and I think it's someone else
oh but tooling in the home during the
day sober in May through November
that's what six months that's so
disappointing like I I'm so upset of
myself okay but like just be proud that
you that I kick to have it yes we're all
proud of you here thank you and I can't
remember the last time not a jolt I
sound like I feel like I sound like I'm
interviewing you as someone who's still
joy no but I'm not I don't know where my
jewel is um but I think never sure I had
on it but I'll live oh yeah the toast
you like are very cute okay next story
very interesting
brought to you by daily harvest we're
all overbooked over stimulated and
constantly running on empty for us we're
always running to produce episodes run
patreon being businesswomen Steen's like
we've lots to do and of programming and
shockingly we barely have enough time to
be complete meals let alone prepare
healthy ones but being busy is not an
excuse it doesn't mean you have to
resort to takeout or overly processed
food and that's why we love dearly
harvest they make easily they make it
easy to eat more fruits and vegetables
with thoughtfully sourced chef crafted
foods that can be prepared in five
minutes or less you get a whole bunch of
em we ordered I think I got my order
like a week ago you keep in the fridge
you keep in the freezer you add ice yet
you really can customize at your own and
I love that they give you like a little
cups take it in so no matter where you
are what you're doing you take that [ __ ]
it takes like one second to prepare and
you run out the house it's real food on
the go each recipe takes one step to
prepare with room to make them your own
you can add your favorite milk or
blended smoothie to blend the smoothie
or heat up a harbor
well and top it with an avocado or a
fried egg you can choose from more than
65 different options like smoothies
hearty soups harvest bowls lattes and
overnight oats whether you're at home at
your desk or on the go
daily harvest is the easiest way to have
a delicious and nutritious meal or snack
daily harvest works directly with
farmers to harvest organic fruits and
vegetables at their pink and freezes
them within 24 hours to lock in their
nutrients everything stays fresh in your
freezer until you're ready to enjoy it
go to daily harvest com enter the promo
code toast to get $25 off your first box
that's promo code toast for $25 off your
first pots at daily harvest com daily
harvest com promo code toast
there's no excuse to be a slob ok yes
Latasha it's it's December we said we're
all getting a jumpstart on our
resolutions my resolution is jumpy a
slob and eat your daily harvest sign on
eat well also daily harvest is one of
those brands that we started working
with on the show that has really changed
my life for the right that it's like
made me like I always am taking like
stuff on the go but to have a really
healthy like a real food option and not
just something that's like a bar yeah
it's been very beneficial for me
yesterday was one of those days where
like I ate nothing but [ __ ] like nothing
of substance
I saw your story oh yeah and I was just
eating crap after crop after crap and I
was so hungry the whole time when I
literally didn't stop eating and it
really makes you realize like when you
eat real food I know it's like so lame
and like our mom it's been telling us
it's like one year when you're eating
like an apple or like a real food like
substance like it goes so much like it
goes so much farther yeah it keeps you
full yeah but it's like snacks with
nachos and they're empty it's empty
couches okay next story exciting news in
the beverage space mmm Pepsi's new
product has nearly twice as much
caffeine as its regular soda so like its
rival coke pepsi is introducing is
launching a new coffee in flick infused
Cola oh it Pepsi Cafe which also comes
in a vanilla flavor will hit shelves
throughout the United States in April
for a limited time it's nearly twice as
caffeinated as regular soda for Pepsi
the new beverage is a way to leverage
consumer trends to invigorate its core
product which could certainly use a
boost so I guess this is also something
that Coke is doing some coffee flavored
soda
that's disgusting at first I thought you
were saying it's just another version of
like Diet Coke or Diet Pepsi that tastes
the same but as double the amount of
caffeine which I was kind of here for
like me as someone who's complete
immune to soda like it's so weird I go
to dinner like frequently with Ben's
family and his mom like loves Diet Coke
more than we do like she is one of us
but when we're at dinner she won't have
it because she says if she's a soda past
three o'clock that she'll be up all
night I'm like are you kidding me like I
could have when I wake up in the middle
of the night and I'm thirsty I'll have a
soda like I am so unaffected by caffeine
so when I thought the product was gonna
be like a really caffeinated soda for
people like me I was so into it but
coffee Cola ill that's really [ __ ]
disgusting it's disgusting and I can't
believe it's like in response to a
coca-cola doing it you know it's weird
a while back I think maybe a year ago we
reported that the soda companies are
gonna start making CBD infused soda so
the opposite of caffeine where it's like
relaxes you but I haven't seen those hit
the shelves yet well because then there
was the FDA said that they banned any
like distribution of like food and
beverage infused to see me day really
yeah the government got involved again
for something so useless Wow interesting
okay I won't be drinking that like I
drink like hands like super cute yeah
they do look really cute that sounds
just so disgusting Starbucks has been
doing this for years you guys yeah and
they put rats in there so does it so
like you're gonna do pudding
you're gonna do 7up yeah okay speaking
of some more poison but with school bus
has been evacuated due to the
overwhelming smell of Axe body spray oh
my god this is so funny also like back
and like coming off the heels of our
viral bus chat last week right acts the
official body spray of men who have a
favorite hockey fight currently
advertises its range of products under
the tagline find your magic but
apparently one person's magic can be
another person's health earned
according to WFTS to school bus carrying
30 students from Buffalo Creek Middle
School in Manatee County Florida of
course that's confusing Buffalo middle
school I was like okay it's obviously a
Buffalo had to be evacuated because one
of them went in hard on the act spray
the bus pulled over at an intersection
and both the Parish Fire Department and
Manatee County emergency medical
services were called to the scene 15
students were treated for mild
respiratory irritation walk but all of
them declined to be transported to a
nearby hospital at this time the
incidents being robbed as a plane a
prank as a deodorant aerosol body spray
was discharged on the bus apparently
this isn't the FIR
time that Axe body spray has required a
bus to pull over oh my god Axe body
spray is so [ __ ] disgusting and it's
it's poison it's causing people
respiratory issues oh my god weak that's
so crazy these poor kids are they okay
yeah I think they're okay when I was in
the eighth grade we went on a school
trip to Israel and like you know when
you're on the trip to Israel in the
desert like you're on the bus the whole
time like the bus is your home the bus
is everything and that was when like all
the kids would wear Axe body spray and
there was a kid in our grade who got
like special treatment because he had
like allergies
he was like respiratory allergic to acts
that we were all on the bus and he got
driven in a car like the whole trip
because he got the school to to pay for
him because he said he was allergic Wow
no and it's a new anything he show Jesus
spare the other children it had will be
that you can't use act he also got to
stay in a different better hotel because
of it we all like worth hating him on
the trip i I literally remember him so
fondly that's gonna beautiful singing
voice because he was protecting his
respiratory actually no and I think that
was part of his excuse that like he
planned on going to Juilliard and like
that's and that he like the school
actually went into it Wow we didn't see
him the whole trip Inter sont [ __ ]
hilarious um so those are the five
stories they told you they were they
were interesting very eclectic they're
eclectic um and I got a message we got a
message that Coach Carr girl sent us an
update oh my god should the book honest
I must be updated oh my god okay I told
you I love okay okay yeah let me have it
we haven't seen the update yet so just
make sure it's kosher to read yeah of
course on the air but I am coach up too
excited and if you're waiting for us to
get this update head over shop twerk
morning toast come to preorder your
toasty Lights sweatshirt very exciting
they're available for pre-order get as
many as you want any size that you want
you will get it in the beginning of
January
ready Jackie and Claudia let me start by
saying I freaked when you read my email
on the toast yesterday at the end of all
this really shitty situation I just feel
like it was worth it because of that and
trust me I definitely understand
Jackie's optimism when I first found out
it was exactly how I felt but as it
turns out he is in fact the rule and not
the exception
oh man I'm heartbroken the day after I
emailed the toast I got a text from him
telling me he could meet up to talk and
explain things he came to my room during
a pip my off period and just continued
to tell me more lies he said things that
made no sense and
had nothing to do with what was actually
going on I literally got up and walked
out of the room he text me again and
thanked me for taking the time to talk
to him and offered that we could talk
and if I needed to say more I waited
until Wednesday night and I sent him a
text finally sticking up for myself I
told him I didn't believe a word he said
and while I would be nice and
professional I basically thought he was
a loser and wanted nothing to do with
him
he then replied with a message about how
he couldn't believe I would say these
things that he was sick and tired of
defending himself when I obviously
didn't want to hear the truth
bla bla bla and then he and the
girlfriend both blocked me on Facebook
the girlfriend blocked him on Facebook
and the other teacher who told me
everything so those the boyfriend the
girlfriend blocked the two teachers I'm
dead so clearly I was right all along
also apparently they are supposed to be
getting engaged soon he was just an ass
looking to get some on the side ah glad
I found out when I did not later but
still all together a very pit inducing
work situation thank you so much for
truly making my year by being on the
toast I will also never refer to my
students as anything but the campers
from here on out thank you so much for
all y'all do I've been around since the
breath and have to say there's nothing
like listening to your favorite comedian
read your email out loud and laugh while
she does it oh my god what a great end
to the story I'm glad she started out
for herself but the girlfriend now
getting involved in blocking her on
Facebook makes me think like did he have
to tell the girlfriend no he probably
told the girlfriend like this crazy girl
that I work with is like no with me the
the man went on her Facebook oh why do
you think that just because maybe he
thought that this girl would like want
to be a hero and message her and be like
hey I know you you're dating this guy
but like I literally had him because he
told me didn't have a girlfriend I'm
like maybe he thought like she would try
and just like you know come clean yeah
and he couldn't take that risk but he
totally blocked her totally there's no
reason why this girl would know about
the teacher and blah and not be like
more curious totally interesting it's
crazy like [ __ ] boys like this are like
in charge of our youth by the way
they're in there molding young minds and
they are their minds need molded
themselves no it's okay this have that
easy gym teacher and it's always the gym
teacher but those who can teach each gym
those who teach gym totally actually
really liked when gym teacher and
there's a lot of different gym teachers
yeah we had a hot one who looks like
Obama but we also had an old one at one
point you were a little mr. Bober yeah
yeah very old he was so old
how we're always playing dodgeball and
it was like survival of the fittest
don't get hurt by the way it's crazy Oh
times have really changed movies you
can't play dodge ball anymore it's not
an acceptable sport for you like the
most
old school gym teacher like he was
getting involved in dodgeball like
taking out his anger on the kids no he
definitely be like I think he made us
stronger people had the weight 1,000
more said I was also his favorite cuz
you guys know I'm so athletic and I'm
also not kidding kids like in gym class
these days like gym class really builds
character back in the day but now with
all these like sensitivities like and
everyone's like allergies to latex like
they can't really get down and dirty
anymore and remember when we used to do
those for the presidential physical
tests yes they were like nationwide test
yes it's like the president is reading
our results of how fast we can run a
mile totally you were like I just want
Bill Clinton to see he doesn't care he's
too busy having sex with Monica Lewinsky
oh my god Wow I wonder what gym class is
like now yet he's so low-impact yeah
actually when I was in a senior in high
school if you weren't on if you were on
like a sports team you didn't have to
take me retire required gym credit but
like I wasn't on a sports team because I
quit the volleyball team after four
years of them like never letting me play
in the disrespect you know I was like
kind of good so I had to end up taking
gym and the gym for seniors was yoga oh
of course
yeah and we used to just like shavasana
and lay on our backs and it was the main
thing I do really liked it it was
hysterical and like they had to it
wasn't like the regular gym teacher who
taught it they like outsourced and
brought in like a contractor and she was
like very into her crafts and like very
like you know green and it was
hysterical oh my god that is so 2020 it
was so 2020 so I went to high school
like the latter end of my high school
was now like more into like the 2020
like sensitive era so we were doing step
aerobics and yoga
that's hilarious but at least I felt
like I was really like healthy at my
core you know I was taking my vitamins
like I really felt like I felt like I
was the picture of health back then when
I look at pictures I wasn't right and
then you were and now you are because of
care of yes because this time of year
it's easy to fall off track when it
comes to your health wellness and
fitness routine as a holidays approach
and things start to get busy are adding
some extra support for energy immunity
and stress can help you find balance and
stay healthy carob makes it super easy
to keep taking your vitamins and
maintaining healthy habits as the cooler
months kick in basically you go online
they let you know exactly what you need
you take a short fun 5 min
as you know we live for a quiz here at
the morning show so it makes us feel
seen and heard you take a five minute
quiz answer easy questions about your
diet your lifestyle and your health
needs you'll get a research backed
recommendation with vitamins supplements
and/or protein powders you need based on
your completely personalized quiz
results you can modify your subscription
at any time when your needs or
preferences change your care of order
gets shipped to you right to your door
and convenient daily packs perfect for a
busy on-the-go lifestyle just throw a
couple in your suitcase when traveling
or one in your bag on the way to the gym
every morning carob is personalized for
you even down to the packaging the
vitamin packs and protein tubs say your
name on them how exciting they are a
vegan and vegetarian supplement options
available and they match your dietary
needs to ensure you're getting the
nutrients you need for those specific
diets um they have a ton of info on how
to compost their packaging on their
website so it's - super sustainable we
love a sustainable brand we do if you
want 50% off your first care up order go
to take care of dot-com enter code toast
50 wow that's a lot 50% off your first
care of order make sure you go to take
care of comm enter the code tous 50 sign
on and get your [ __ ] together because
it's December and if not now says well
yeah we're giving you all the tools here
at the morning toast to get your [ __ ]
together for the new year with the promo
code like you're welcome if it's okay
when I logged into the dear toasters
email I did see an email with a subject
line that just rang my bell
oh I would love you know we do have some
extra time and I would love it your
toasters because they've really shaped
my week like I've just been thinking oh
man about everyone's I'm sorry I can't
read this one it is far too long but the
subject line was it's not my fault that
your husband sucks oh okay here's
another one and we got an update from it
okay and it's not that long it's called
nepotism but like not the good kind
hello again toast oh this is her update
let me read her original email let's
hear it exciting such a dear toasters
week oh it's an update do you remember
oh my god the last time I wrote in I
asked for advice on my not so Anthony
Ches that was mysteriously being fired
exploiting my work and owed me an Ag a
member yes and so to wrap that side of
the story I never got my money back but
I did gain new insight as to why my aunt
was like Oh from my current job she was
sleeping with my boss the true one not
my supervisor Mike who was a part of the
original story but this is he the T
thickens a couple months ago my cube
mate is that like
cubicle man yeah we'll call her
Christina she's 25 confided to me that
she was starting to get a mega crush on
our boss the one that Linda slept with
he's married in his 50s
Christina used to tell stories about her
and her girlfriend Jen who she lived
with and that they were starting to have
relationship problems she also told me
that she left her last job because she
started hooking up with her boss who was
Jen oh my god okay so her co-worker
ended up at her last job moving in with
her boss because she hooked up with her
boss and now she's starting to have a
cross a crush on a merman boss who was
the same woman who the aunt [ __ ] and
got let go oh my god I'm dying what
[ __ ] company is this since that
conversation she has started to spend a
lot more time with our boss we'll call
him Charles in his office alone fast
forward a couple weeks Christina pulled
me into an empty office and disclosed
that her and our boss had been going to
secret dinners and staying up super late
in the office when no one was around she
said that nothing had happened beyond a
PG movie but like what the [ __ ] does
that mean
fast-forward again two days ago
Christina came in late to work told the
story of a hotel valet who mistook her
for Charles's daughter and then showed
me a picture of her view from a fancy
hotel room so when I used the context
clues to put together they had spent the
night together later in the conversation
she had joked but they had done some
quote unquote stuff but then past the
point of no return so like they def fact
which was the lair confirmed since then
she's been very vocal about her
relationship with Jenny even though they
are no longer together as a way to
misdirect that anyone who might be
suspicious of her and Charles being
alone
I guess she's fluid which is high key
strategic AAF I'm clearly clearly the
only one Christina has told and pardon
me wants to be supportive outlets to
talk to but another part of me has been
trying to distance myself so I can play
the bit long story short my aunt is
Nikkei I haven't slept with my boss who
was also sleeping with my 25 year old to
keep me is this a normal thing that I
should but out of it's not my business
and I'm not here to snitch but like what
the [ __ ] do I do with this information
thanks for listening and oh gee toaster
it's a normal thing I need to know what
brothel you work at because I've never
heard of people having issues like this
in the workplace and [ __ ] stay the [ __ ]
out of it this is an HR nightmare okay
yeah this is like compliance this is
sexual harassment
this is so many issues and you need not
be brought into this like let everyone
everyone has made their bends now let
them [ __ ] it without you getting
involved exactly it's 11:11 make-a-wish
honestly I'm really still holding out
hope for Gabrielle Union because more
details are coming out about this like
that Gigi or that there was a report
saying that people were going around
saying that all of the hairstyles that
she was sporting on her various looks
during her time on America's Got Talent
were too black yeah that was in the
initial report oh I just heard that so
terrible
so justice for
her and justice for Joycelyn if she
wants it because I still don't know if
Joycelyn who was one of our Kelly's most
notorious victims like is coming out or
not because she's giving conflicting
messages on her patreon account yeah I
haven't been able to saddle up like the
ten bucks because I just I don't think
it's real no I can't believe that that
might be a hose
we need one tow start to buy the patreon
and just someone has and they put in the
recaps but there's so no way to know
that if it's actually her or like her
sister I have no idea
terrible well that concludes our show
for you guys I'm heading over to Verona
New York right now gonna be near
Syracuse at the Turning Stone Casino
can't wait to see you guys there
oh by the way it's Taylor Swift's
birthday oh my god it's December's and
also Friday the 13th spooky and it's
also Colgate Day which is exciting
because I'm going up you wanna come with
me
you're gonna be so close to Colgate I
know it's Telstra's birthday happy 30th
for they tell her thank you for being a
positive light in my life I love you
more than anything I think you're the
most beautiful human being in the world
and all the art you create I have
appreciated since a very young age of
like 12 and I just love you so much and
I'm so glad that you are the woman of
the decade because you're the woman of
my decade very sweet thank you so much
rolls it into the morning toast Molino
morning show will we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please please subscribe you give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio I
Heart Radio cast box all the apps so
wherever you listen to podcasts make
sure you're subscribed and leave a five
star review about how this beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much heaven have an amazing
Friday amazing weekend don't drink and
drive and we will see you on Monday and
if you want a toasty life sweatshirt
head over to chop Marine toast calm
they'll be available for pre-order until
Monday morning and then it will be
closed we'll be placing your orders and
shipping them out as soon as possible so
if you are a miss devastated and
heartbroken that you did not get one
head to shop morning toast calm now and
get one also if you order anything else
with that the whole order will ship in
January so if you want something now
don't order it with the sweatshirt
that's good advice yeah I think everyone
should know by all
you